so the man targeted Greg price joins us
now he's the senior digital strategies
at X strategies um Now Greg here's what
NBC said about your videos the videos
include slight edits such as cutting out
the sound of the audience to make it
appear as if he had abruptly stopped
speaking other edits cut fetterman off
mid-sentence to create the perception
that what he was saying was nonsensical
sounds like what they've done to me like
all the time when they edit my stuff uh
thoughts no so anyone who follows me on
Twitter knows that I'm really big into
making Super Cuts which are just these
these small little clips that are part
of a larger video to make a broader
point and the point in this case is that
John fetterman had a stroke not too long
ago which is sad we pray that his health
for covers but he has serious issues
speaking about it or he's serious as
she's speaking and when and when you're
running for the United States Senate
that's a legitimate criticism as even
the Washington Post editorial board said
and so I've made about like three or
four really viral Supercuts of John
fetterman of clips of him at his rallies
where he's barely able to get through
them and obviously obviously his
handlers don't let him speak for very
long periods at a time and so after my
latest one I get this DM from this NBC
news reporter and he basically is asking
me about the edits that I made and why I
did them about the Supercut he DM me
another video that I'd also reposted
from a different account that cut out
the audience clapping in it and
basically to claim that that was that
was doctored and made his speech issues
look worse than they were and so in my
head I was thinking to my civil case
probably writing some stupid article
about our Republicans are being mean to
John fetterman and then he publishes it
and he accuses me of doctoring the video
not selectively editing not taking out
of context but doctoring them as if I
had like somehow deep faked these videos
to make it look like John Federman had
worse speech issues than than he
actually does and like the way I thought
journalism was supposed to work is
journalism is supposed to challenge
powerful people and challenge powerful
institutions in America but in this case
this NBC news reporter is accusing me of
doctoring videos and then going to Big
tech companies asking them to censor me
they're you know the own holy alliance
between media and big Tech and instead
of like asking why you know John
fetterman's handlers are not letting him
speak for like only short times they're
accusing me of doctoring the videos and
trying to censor me well Greg in the
last hour on MSNBC fetterman was
actually asked about this
there are viral videos mashups of your I
think cognitive or vocal errors things
that they think suggest cognitive
decline what do you say to Pennsylvania
voters who see some of this stuff on the
internet who hear the ads from Dr Oz's
camp and are worried about your Fitness
for office I'm absolutely fit to serve I
just can confirm I would just took a
test uh just I think it was yesterday
that that confirmed that I'm absolutely
fully functioning and in the ranges as
well too uh the the one side that wants
to try to lie about that
response my response to that is just
prove it debate Dr Oz about conditions
and we're going to get to that in a
moment debate Dr Oz at a time sooner
than two weeks before the election all
right Greg we reached out to fetterman
as campaign they didn't respond to us on
this particular issue but they did tell
NBC it's pretty sad and frankly
desperate that Dr Oz's Maga allies are
deceptively editing videos of John
speaking in order to mock him while he
recovers from a stroke quickly your
response well I think it's pretty sad
that they're trying to pull the wool
over the eyes of Pennsylvania voters and
are trying to act like this man is a lot
healthier than it is which Again The
Washington Post editorial board called
them out for and forget just his health
issues this guy has really bad ideas
that would be bad for Pennsylvania and
the country and they're trying to pull
the same Playbook they did with Joe
Biden by essentially just keeping him in
the basement and trying you know to
convince Pennsylvania voters what's the
worst this guy could do but this guy
wants to release one-third of prisoners
from prison like he's he has a lot of
terrible ideas and if he gets elected
he's going to enact them and they're
basically just trying to trick PA voters
into doing it Greg great to see you
tonight thank you for your work